karingana wa karingana era uma vez
assim começam as histórias eu vim aqui
falar sobre histórias a importância que
elas têm e porque queremos contar
eu costumo dizer que sempre foi
apaixonada por histórias histórias foram
no primeiro grande amor itco de
histórias nos livros
quando era pequena comecei a ler livros
como toquinho vermelho os três
porquinhos
acho que todos vocês conhecem marina e
aprendi algumas lições importantes
a primeira é quando vou vir sempre a
minha mãe
o capuchinho vermelho disso muito mal
com essa história de não ouvir a mãe
aprende com os três porquinhos que
devemos também ser amigos nossos irmãos
só tem um som muito amiga dele e fui
aprendendo várias lições e também
coleções como anita ainda vai à escola e
da fajã anos acho que você também
conhece a coleção de anita
li também uma aventura uma aventura
extremosa uma aventura na praia e foram
estas coleções este livro estas
histórias como permitiram imaginar
outros mundos para além daquele onde eu
estava
foi através dessas histórias que eu
aprendi o que eram castelos o que era
neve o que eram grutas essa história
ensinaram também que havia uma
experiência da humanidade partilhada por
que nessa história toda sua sentir um
frio
senti um calor choravam região que são
emoções que também sentia aqui no meu
mundo então histórias pra mim sempre
foram uma espécie de refúgio
sempre gostei de ler esse gosto pela
leitura de histórias mesmo também ganhar
gosto por contar histórias e escrever
veio uma muito naturalmente
comecei a escrever acho que quando
aprende a minha primeira letra e escrevi
há postais do dia da mãe do pai
aniversário natal
você acha que eu devo pequenos poemas
crônicas e enfim escrever um pouco de
tudo sempre na esperança de imaginar um
novo mundo e opinar esse mundo com
castelos com neve ligações sem fios
chorou e subir na faculdade passei por
obrigação
passei a ler artigos científicos livros
muito técnicos
ia com o objetivo apenas de passar
aquela cadeira pra ter prefeitura é
então perdi aqui um gosto e prazer que a
história me davam porque não estava a
ler histórias mas ainda assim olhava pra
mim e pensava eliana duas uma contadora
de histórias todas elas muito bem apesar
de não contar histórias em 2014 nos de
reencontrar esse lado que eu sempre
gostei chegou às minhas mãos um livro
chamado limitado de um só amarelo que é
da irmandade tinha uma altura gitana e
este livro conta a guerra do biafra
guerra civil da nigéria sobre os olhos
de uma família que se despedaçou e ao
mesmo tempo se aproximou
isso é uma experiência fantástica para
mim era aquele livro daquele livro
permite um não descobrir um novo mundo
necessariamente mas olhar pro meu mundo
e pensar na história que estavam
escondidas nesse mundo
eu pensei em moçambique também ficará
civil acredita que muitas famílias
também se despedaçaram se aproximaram
servido como muitas coincidências muitos
encontros e desencontros por conta da
guerra mas eu nunca tenha lido algo
assim algo que me descrever essa
experiência
isso despertou uma idéia de como
curiosidade para descobrir então esse
mundo o meu mundo é verde pensar noutros
mundos descobrir esse onde eu estava
foi assim em 2015 desafiei ler um livro
por mês
ontem dois meses fazendo a condição dos
livros por ano pensa que é um número
absurdo o suficiente para eu cumprir sem
me assustar não era 10
eu achava pouco feminina 20 que eu
achava muito e foi o que aconteceu em
2015 ele estes livros todos e foi um ano
muito intenso um ano você olhar mais
para este mundo mais pra mim e olhar
para a história como reflexo de quem eu
sou e não como o fluxo de como as outras
pessoas são
em 2015 eu descobri h o ghana através de
jogos detalhe assim eu descobri a
nigéria através do jorge do leitor inca
eu descobri outro moçambicano através do
jorge da ilha montanha
toda essa história são duas histórias no
total permitiram viajar dentro deste
espaço em que eu me encontro permitiram
descobrir que havia muito mais para além
do que eu consigo ver que havia
histórias ainda por contar aqui que não
precisava procurar transitórios e acima
tudo ler sobre histórias são parecidas
a minha ler sobre o mundo estão partir
do meu fez me entender que a literatura
não deve ser algo que nós usamos para
escapar mas sim para descobrir litro
deve ser um direito humano
todos nós temos feito a nossa voz contra
a nossa verdade
e nesse sentido todos nós também temos
direito a ler a nossa história ler a
nossa verdade em 2016
continuei e mais livros lá até hoje ali
mais 30 estão apenas alguns
acho que a experiência mas impactante
talvez poderia e um fato curioso é que
eu tive o privilégio de ler o primeiro
livro editado e publicado por uma
escritora africana no ano passado
é o livro é furo essa imagem do flora no
mapa
o livro conta a história de furo que é
uma jovem mulher conta a história de
lula desde sua infância até a fase
adulta todos os ritos de iniciação
porque ela passa todas as fases das
expectativas que há de ser uma boa
mulher uma bobina uma boa mãe
o livro escrito em 1966 foi um tanto
comigo eu comecei a pensar só na nova
conseguiu escrever essa história há não
sei quantos anos atrás mas 50 anos atrás
e é uma história que até hoje levando
pra mim porque eu juro muito que quer
ser uma boa mulher
será que alguém alguma vez vai conseguir
alcançar esse ideal será que há uma
mulher que pode dizer se eu me considero
uma boa mulher que as pessoas conseguem
reconhecer que ela é uma boa mulher
perceber que é preciso também contar
essas histórias e se não tivesse lido
anita vai à escola anita fajã estivesse
unido como anita para o bazar ainda vai
fazer tranças e cerveja ser uma aventura
extrema chuvoso nova entrou na ponta do
ouro uma aventura na cala não seria mais
interessante
estou de nós pudéssemos ter esse livro
não só cá pensei nisto
aquilo que nós poderíamos ter
conquistado a área como um lugar para
deixar algo que daqui a 50 anos alguém
pudesse ler e pensar na eliana e pensar
que acusar de 50 anos de distância a um
espaço partilhado e as emoções que são
em temporais que qualquer outra mulher
no meu lugar havia de se sentir assim
não importa daqui a 20 anos não importa
quanto tempo passado não importa se
fosse aqui na nigéria lugar em angola
todos nós temos esse espaço do partido
negociação entre o moderno eo
tradicional entra o profissional do
pessoal entre o individual eo coletivo
todos nós temos essa vontade
eu queria deixar esse desafio pra vocês
essa história existem elas já estão
escondidas
imagine se cada um de vocês agora
acredito vai ler um livro só um
a partir de hoje um livro este ano
escrito por um autor africano
afrodescendente
imaginem quantos livros todos nós mesmos
um livro diferente quanto a história nós
não iríamos encontrar
e agora tem uma proposta ainda mais
ambiciosa isso cada um de nós disse que
vai escrever uma história a partir de
hoje vamos escrever uma história que de
alguma forma prudente quem nós somos o
que nós fazemos e esse tempo e espaço em
que nós estamos agora daqui a 50 anos
quando as pessoas tenham o privilégio de
jogar nisso e de entender melhor o nosso
mundo porque essa história já existem e
na verdade nem acho que ninguém vai ler
porque elas não estão acessíveis a todos
só nós prevemos essa história nós
queremos a nossa verdade é que ela será
conhecida por isso não vou escrever
outras verdades
vamos continuar a ler sobre o castelo de
sobre a neve e nunca ninguém vai saber
a dor que é sendo 15 horas patrão sá é
que nunca ninguém vai saber o que era lá
coco que o que é pior amendoim o que é
estar aqui no tek maputo
são histórias que nós temos que
partilhar nós temos que deixar essa
história registados pra gerações
vindouras e eu tenho o meu mantra é
muito simples discreto ele escreve e
esse mantra é que me trouxe até aqui foi
porque eu comecei um dia escrever quem
ariano que ele não pensava que outras
portas abriram-se até mim
em outras oportunidades surgirão e entra
nesse madrid eu descobri que o meu lugar
na terra não é necessariamente definido
pelo único nesse ano eu vou morrer mas
sim porque eu vou deixar para as pessoas
lerem sobre mim e sobre aquilo que eu
vivi
deixa isso pra vocês leiam mais e crepom
muito para enganar o cara enganar
era uma vez
[Aplausos]